de la télévision peut-être une thérapie
bien sûr mais parler est une thérapie la
télévision est-elle le lieu propice à la
révélation d'une intimité nous sommes
dans un monde voyeur les émissions a
tendance psy court sur beaucoup de
chaînes et nous en parlerons d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure avec Mireille Dumas mais
auparavant petit rappel historique de
ces émissions qui sont quand même de
drôles de programme Olivia delpo ce qui
fait donc aujourd'hui pour vous
qu'il soit si difficile
de vivre l'un avec l'autre nos
difficultés sexuelles scandale et
polémiques psycho débarque en 83 sur
Antenne 2 une tentative d'introduire la
psychanalyse à la télévision voulue par
Pascal brognod psycho a une mission
sociale elle sait de quoi elle parle
ayant fait une analyse et ayant eu un
certain plaisir à jouer avec humour avec
ma propre expérience surtout que c'était
une expérience intéressante à
communiquer aux gens et essayer de
raconter au spectateur et un peu les
voix de l'inconscient si tu as la façon
dont l'inconscient peut nous manipuler
pour nous faire faire des choses
qu'apparemment on n'a pas envie de faire
et finalement qu'on est conduit à faire
par des voies secrètes
vous aimez Gérard vous lui dites un
grand nom de la psychanalyse Serge
Leclerc se prête au jeu de la thérapie
télévisée malgré ça l'expérience ne
durera pas très longtemps il était
peut-être trop tôt pour les mentalités
les gens au début ont été très choqués
par la forme de l'émission par le
l'aspect très indiscret de cette vie de
couple mise au grand jour et puis
finalement après ils ont compris le sens
de l'émission c'est venu petit à petit
ils ont compris qu'on parlait de choses
finalement plus complexe qu'il n'avait
l'air c'était pas simplement une
confession mais que cette terre
racontait aux gens comment fonctionne
les affects les êtres à la vie affective
des êtres six ans plus tard parce
qu'elle Brognon est sur TF1 avec l'amour
en danger rien à voir avec si chaud
cette fois-ci c'est du spectacle du psy
pas si sûr et ça fait de l'audience
à Marjorie et à Gérard
je crois que vous ne vous êtes jamais
marié
le travail que j'ai fait avec eux c'est
de leur permettre de revivre cette
histoire comme étant la leur
c'est-à-dire moi j'ai pris les éléments
je leur ai raconté autrement d'une façon
plus romanesque aussi qui était souvent
plus belle et ils se sont dit ça c'est
mon histoire avec mon histoire je peux
faire quelque chose je t'aime je peux
pas me donner de toi mise en scène
reconstitution les couples jouent en
plateau ce qu'ils ne font plus dans la
vie à destination d'un téléspectateur
fasciné sans doute aussi mal à l'aise
peut-être bien du voyeurisme les gens se
confiaient regardez quelqu'un qui se
confie en soi c'est pas de voyeurisme ça
dépend ce que vous pensez dans votre
cœur si vous êtes touché par l'histoire
de cette personne si vous avez envie d'y
compatir si vous dites dans le fond ce
qui lui est arrivé elle peut-être que ça
m'arrive à moi que ça m'arrive à mon
fils soit ma voisine je vais aller
regarder si je peux pas l'aider vous
êtes pas ailleurs vous êtes un être
humain totalement humain petit retour en
arrière au début des années 80 sur TF1
la psy est à la mode et sert de prétexte
pour interviewer des stars une ambiance
mondaine un psy raffinée qui découvre
dans l'inconscient de Gilbert Bécaud
qu'il est un bon papa avec les gens qui
vous sont chers avec vos enfants votre
famille vos amis un vrai décor de séance
freudienne le divan la route depuis 7
ans de la psy pas tout à fait mais un
homme de télévision qui revendique le
ton convenable de ses entretiens c'est
pas la question je ne pense pas des
questions horripilandes gênantes et
intime des questions qui salissent en
quelque sorte l'individu comment le fait
trop souvent à la télévision je n'aimais
pas dans l'embarras et je les insulte
pas voilà c'est très démodé ce que je
fais là mais j'aime ça là où il y a
cardinal et quelle petite fille
étiez-vous à l'âge de 7 ans
très timide très renfermé je ne parlais
presque pas et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que j'ai cette voix rock
mais c'est très différent selon que vous
regardez ou pas l'interlocuteur le fait
d'être derrière bien que ce soit une
mission de télé ça change complètement
et Sigmund au fait qu'en penses-tu
Mireille Dumas des masques n'a rien à
voir avec tout ce que nous venons de
regarder là à l'instant c'est très très
différent
j'ai du mal j'ai vraiment du mal avec
les reconstitutions en plateau le rallye
ticho comme ça oui moi ça me met très
très mal à l'aise vous n'êtes pas du
tout psychanalyste pas du tout ça n'a
rien à voir ce que je fais
rien à voir moi c'est vrai que je pars
du discours intime aussi c'est vrai que
je questionne la personne sur son sur
son cheminement mais ça débouche sur un
problème de société
toute la différence c'est que
effectivement il y a de la psychologie
mais surtout surtout je pose un problème
aux collectif je crois que ça c'est
important mais vous savez aussi que la
télévision peut être une thérapie bien
sûr mais parler est une thérapie je
crois que c'est pour ça que très très
souvent on me dit mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas vous aussi psychothérapeute
parce que le fait de s'exprimer et étant
soit une thérapie non moi ce que j'ai
envie de dire et je crois que si
beaucoup de personnes viennent
s'exprimer devant des millions de
téléspectateurs c'est qu'elles ont envie
d'être entendues d'être reconnus à part
entière comme individu comme personne
appartenant à cette société et ça c'est
important mais comme n'importe qui c'est
à dire moi aussi je suis là j'existe et
j'ai envie qu'on m'entende mais qu'il ne
voudrait pas une seule fois dans les
mains que vous n'êtes pas tomber dans le
voyeurisme parce que quand même il y a
des confidences qui vont très très loin
j'essaie de j'essaie vous savez d'éviter
bien sûr et souvent ce que je dis c'est
que j'essaie de porter l'autre à devenir
voyant et non pas voyeur ce qui est très
très différent c'est essayer d'aller
derrière les apparences essayer de
comprendre comment l'autre fonctionne et
je crois que le téléspectateur
finalement se met dans la même position
que l'interviewer il est à côté de vous
donc tout dépend de votre positionnement
à vous
d'interviewer je crois que ça c'était
sensible
que nous avons vu à l'instant mais
quelques années
rien parce que je trouve qu'il fait très
très bien son travail mais c'est vrai
que l'amour en danger moi ça me donnait
de l'urticaire maintenant vous savez que
je sais que beaucoup d'hommes je donne
de l'urticaire à beaucoup d'hommes qui
trouvent que bah les masques justement
parfois peut peut être voyeuriste et je
crois que ça vient des hommes je ne l'ai
jamais entendu dans la bouche d'une
femme et je crois que les femmes on a
une façon de procéder qui est un peu
différente c'est qu'on est tout de suite
je suis désolé j'arrive tout de suite au
coeur et que tout de suite au coeur du
sujet et on c'est vrai qu'on ne
s'embarrasse peut-être pas de de
préliminaires contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer vous avez le droit de
but mais oui oui et en même temps en
essayant d'aller loin ça fait quand même
beaucoup de malheur joyeusement déversé
ça fait beaucoup de malheur joyeusement
déversé c'est vrai c'est vrai mais vous
savez pourquoi aussi l'émission
fonctionne je crois que souvent ceux qui
la regardent pas beaucoup ont une image
déformée en disant effectivement c'est
une émission où on parle de tous les
malheurs de l'humanité je crois qu'on
parle de souvent mais pas toujours pas
toujours justement de problèmes graves
de problèmes de société qui sont qui
sont graves difficiles parfois entendre
à chaque fois ce sont des personnes qui
ont fait tout un cheminement qui se sont
battus qui et qui tout le temps donne
des possibilités de s'en sortir et je
crois que c'était essentiel donc c'est
une c'est une émission qui propulse elle
n'est pas fermée elle n'est pas sinistre
j'en ai assez d'entendre tant de
confidences je le dis parce que
l'émission continue bien sûr bien sûr
que la mission continue mais est-ce que
vous savez depuis combien de temps moi
je fais ce genre quand même deux non pas
des missions puisque bas les masques
effectivement est un concept de qui date
d'il y a deux ans mais en tout cas cette
parole individuelle qui pose un problème
de société ça fait quand même 11 ans je
fais ça à la télévision donc ce n'est
pas je ne suis pas moi dans la mode là
où vous êtes dangereuse Mireille
d'humain c'est que vous travaillez dans
la douceur dans la caresse oui mais
c'est pire que tout mais
j'étais sûr que vous alliez me dire ça
vous le savez d'ailleurs alors je vais
vous dire je ne cherche pas si c'était
pour piéger évidemment que je serai
dangereuse si c'était en direct
évidemment je serai dangereuse mais moi
si je travaille comme vous dites dans la
douceur d'abord je suis comme ça je ne
sais pas d'être quelqu'un d'autre et
l'émission n'est pas en direct donc
j'essaie simplement d'aller le plus loin
possible d'accompagner l'autre le plus
loin possible c'est de la maïeutique ce
que je pratique
parfois le meilleur oui bien sûr
moi-même j'ai mes propres dérapages et
l'autre peut à tout moment déraper et à
ce moment-là évidemment il y a
heureusement qu'il y a le montage alors
mardi prochain bas les masques consacre
son émission à la séduction tout à fait
je dois dire que là
vous obtenez des aveux surprenants dans
la drague c'est toute la violence qu'il
faut affronter envers soi envers les
autres et c'est de la j'ai quelque part
c'est de la méchanceté de la pathologie
et c'est il faut que ce soit assumé
c'est à dire que on se drogue pour se
faire du mal hein et moi quand je drague
c'est pour ça que j'ai aimé aller au
fond de la drague la drague de rue dans
le supermarché c'est que j'aime j'aime
je le savoir comme une déchéance c'est à
dire que j'ai du mal à passer des femmes
au lieu de me raconter autre chose comme
beaucoup de connards qui dit tu n'es
qu'une [__] ou des trucs comme ça moi je
fais autre chose et puis on découvre
qu'en douce ils mettent là ils ont
l'espèce de main transpirante qui glisse
sous la table et qui a une fille etc
j'ai préféré aller au fond du trou et au
moins voir ce qui se passait au fond et
d'ailleurs moi j'ai fait un parcours de
drague de rue intégrale alors que
j'avais le choix parce que j'ai démarré
plutôt comme j'ai démarré assez fort
quand je suis arrivé à Paris je suis
tout de suite j'ai tout de suite pu me
ranger dans la catégorie séducteur parce
que j'ai je dirais levé des filles de
riches etc et à un moment donné je me
suis rendu compte par des rencontres que
la drague de rue était beaucoup plus
courageuse beaucoup plus valable et au
moins que c'était assumé le truc et j'ai
choisi ça avant que vous ne continuiez
vous venez de quel milieu vous étiez
d'un milieu bourgeois mais très déclassé
pauvre et je me disais bon je suis dans
la grande ville plein de manque et plein
de désirs avec le côté manque social
d'argent puis il manque affectif qui
était ses parents très jeunes de
conscient du conditions difficiles et je
voyais c'est une image qui m'est restait
en tête il y a une Ferrari qui passe
dans la rue et une fille avec une jupe
rouge de la même couleur qui passe à
côté et je me dis la Ferrari pour monter
dedans c'est 80 briques ou alors on la
vole et ça peut être deux ans de prison
la fille si on sait y faire c'est
gratuit et même ça peut rapporter
Mireille Jacques Pradel n'est jamais
allé jusque là mais enfin c'est plus de
la séduction c'est de la drague vous
parlez de la drague tout à fait alors je
vais vous dire toute la différence avec
avec certaines émissions je crois c'est
que moi je n'ai pas des gens qui
viennent en plateau
chercher la parole de la parole du
maître la parole du psy et qui viennent
en disant expliquer nous pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas moi j'ai des gens qui
assument là c'est vous venez d'entendre
Alain Soral témoigner il assume
complètement
bien sûr mais parce qu'il réfléchit et
c'est pour ça que cette émission peut
continuer et à mon avis nous préserve de
tout voyeurisme c'est parce que les gens
viennent avec cette parole assumer
qu'ils ont réfléchi et parce qu'ils ont
compris quelque chose à leur propre
parcours ils peuvent en témoigner devant
les autres c'est très différent alors
Mireille du mal vous êtes prêts du
Premier ministre pour une action c'est
pas euh
comme ça une enquête auprès des jeunes
qui est complètement impolitique
constituée de personnes et entre autres
j'y suis de personnalité qui toutes ont
un lien avec les jeunes ça c'est
important que ça que ce soit le
commissaire de police que ce soit le
proviseur que ce soit
un rapport que ce soit le journaliste
qui parle de problèmes de société et on
est comme dans toute commission des
personnes complètement indépendantes ce
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'étiquette
politique et nous sommes là pour
constituer un questionnaire le proposer
aux jeunes récolter ce questionnaire et
ensuite
c'est un rapport tout simplement en tout
cas une chose est sûre bas les masques
continue tout à fait la dernière de la
saison
et vous reprenez en septembre dans la
même forme du changement oui on va bien
sûr qu'on va un peu changer vous savez
moi j'aime bien évoluer je me sens
quelqu'un de profondément vivant donc ça
va bouger merci Mireille
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas
[Musique]